so good afternoon it's great to see
everyone here today and I'm delighted to
talk to you about the economics of
virtual currency and Bitcoin and this
topic has been just an incredibly fun
and exciting topic to research and learn
about it's emerged in in the public
imagination over the last two or three
years as a key piece of technology that
might really change the way finance
works for consumers for people in
developing countries and for the way
that financial institutions actually
conduct their business so one of the
things that's challenging about this
technology is that there's so many
details about it about how it works and
just like in the early days of the
internet if you went to a conference
about the internet you would hear people
talking about protocols and SMTP and FTP
and how we get packets around and really
none of the things that you would talk
about and that kind of a technical
environment would really be important
for knowing whether you should start
amazon.com or eBay or whether you should
invent PayPal or whether pets.com would
succeed or fail and so similarly for
Bitcoin a lot of the details of how the
technology works can really be separated
from what the technology is and what it
does and so what I want to talk about
today is really what this technology is
and what kinds of things it can empower
and then we can all sort of use our
collective imaginations to think about
where it's going to go and just like
having this conversation in 1993 or 1994
we could have very informed guesses
based on economics and needs and
shipping cost and warehouse cost and
logistics and communication needs
we could make some very interesting
predictions probably none of us would
have realized how exciting YouTube or
Twitter or you know all these other
things that people figured out to do
later would be and so in a similar way
we're not going to be able to fully
forecast the best uses of this new
technology so at its really fundamental
level Bitcoin is
something quite simple um it's a
spreadsheet it's a big spreadsheet now
you might think well wait Lotus 1-2-3
was invented and you know around the
1980s so what's new here and in fact
really to think about the history of
spreadsheets we need to go back before
they were called spreadsheets
um they were actually called Ledger's
and so in the beginning of Commerce you
know in primitive economies you might
have learned in some class that people
bartered you know an apple for an orange
or you know what a dead deer for uh you
know a hunting knife
but in fact that is really not how
commerce emerged for the most part even
in fairly primitive societies use
Ledger's going way way back in time so
it's kind of complicated to actually
have two things one in each hand and
trade them for each other and so it's
been very natural for human societies to
use Ledger's to keep track of things so
that I can contribute today and get
something back tomorrow so really the
origin of money itself is a ledger
before there was money there were
Ledger's that kept track of who had what
and who had contributed so bitcoin is in
its essence a big spreadsheet or a big
public ledger and what it does is it
keeps track of who has sent want to whom
so it's going to say that you know
person one two three sent one Bitcoin to
person four five six okay that's what it
does and that's pretty much all that it
does so how can this be you know so
innovative and you know so so exciting
if that's all it does well if you
imagine for a second that we just put up
a big spreadsheet that kept track of
trillions of dollars and we just posted
it on the internet from a server what do
you think would happen so I might hack
that server and try to change the ledger
in some way so if you're going to have a
ledger that keeps track of things that
are very very valuable it's very
important that it's secure that's one
thing and so what I won't tell you how
that works today but I'll say that one
of the big innovations in the invention
of Bitcoin was a method to keep that
ledger secure and the
way that that's done is it there's
actually not one computer that's holding
that ledger because pretty much any one
computer is hackable but rather copies
of that ledger are kept all over the
world and they all have to agree not all
a majority has to agree on what the
correct ledger is and so if anyone or if
even 20 percent or 30 percent of those
where hacked or changed or altered in
some way that still wouldn't change the
full public record so this distributed
technology of course only really enabled
by the internet to be able to distribute
something so widely and easily is part
of the security about how this works a
second thing is that you know if we
wanted to have a big ledger to keep
track of things it would be natural to
think about sort of having somebody in
charge of keeping track of it and so you
know you could have PayPal PayPal
creates a big ledger if you have an
account on PayPal and you send it to
someone else on PayPal and you both
carrying balances no money actually
moves just PayPal makes a debit on one
side and a credit on another side and
nothing else has to happen but now you
have PayPal a company that's keeping
track of that ledger okay
the thing about a Bitcoin is that it's
an open source software protocol that
allows people to make their own entries
on the ledger in a decentralized fashion
so if you own a Bitcoin that means sort
of two things one is that you have the
address for the Bitcoin and someone has
sent it to you so there has to be an
entry on a ledger saying you have it but
that's not enough because you also need
a security key or a password to
authorize a movement of that Bitcoin to
someone else if you don't have the
passcode you can look out at that ledger
and admire your beautiful Bitcoin
sitting there but you can't do anything
with it so you could say that you own it
but it's not really meaningful that you
own it because you can't move it if you
have the password and you have an entry
on the ledger that says it's yours then
you have something a value that you can
actually do something with and what can
you do with it
exactly one thing you can authorize a
movement to someone else okay but
hopefully that person is going to give
you something back and that's what makes
it useful okay so that's it big public
spreadsheet with some passwords and some
really cool ways to keep it from getting
hacked alright so why is that important
and sort of useful well first of all
it's the first time that we have a
purely digital asset where the whole
definition of owning that asset is just
the digital thing there is no
corresponding physical asset and that's
going to allow many things probably the
the easiest thing is just that I can
send something of value to you digitally
it with the same kind of timeframe and
user experience as sending an email
that's something I can do globally I can
do it without asking anybody's
permission without requiring some other
institution to do something for me I can
just do it I could meet somebody on a
chat room and have them email me a
digital good or provide me a service and
I could extend them back something of
value and we could be done in ten
minutes and never have to see each other
again okay that's pretty powerful so
what's going to happen is if you know
this person wants to send a Bitcoin to
someone else they're going to have a
certain address they're going to enter
their password they're going to
authorize a movement of one Bitcoin say
it doesn't have to be one to someone
else and then ten minutes later that
shows up is a new entry on the ledger
okay and that's a instantaneous not
quite instantaneous but very fast
movement of an asset that in a way
that's really not possible using other
technologies so if you want to see how
this looks from a user's perspective a
user can use something called a wallet
and a wallet is just a piece of software
that looks out at that whole big ledger
which is very very very long by now and
looks at just the transactions that are
important to you that are associated
with your addresses and displays to you
your balances it's just a very simple
piece of software and it'll help you
keep track of your passwords and things
like that now as an economist I you know
look at this it's very cool it's very
neat but an important early question to
ask is well why a Bitcoin did you just
make up this idea of a Bitcoin either to
be a ponzi scheme or something cool a
gimmick you know that makes people
excited about your new product like you
know most people don't want to think
about holding an asset whose value
fluctuates you know if you want to hold
an asset if you want to hold cash you
want to hold cash in the currency that
you're going to spend it in you don't
want to walk around you know holding
your own
if you're going to spend dollars it's
not convenient you have to keep track of
the u.s. two euro exchange rate and
similarly it's very inconvenient for you
to hold say something called a Bitcoin
when you're going to go ultimately pay
things that are priced in dollars so can
we just get rid of this whole Bitcoin
thing and use this really cool
spreadsheet but actually keep track of
dollars okay so let's just put dollars
on a spreadsheet well let's talk a
minute about what that means so the guys
who invented this security technology
we're really really smart but
unfortunately they did not figure out
how I could be mad ollar bill onto your
keyboard I can't go zoom and a dollar
bill appears not possible so if I had a
password and authorized an entry on that
spreadsheet that said I gave you a
dollar of course that would be an
incomplete description of what happened
because I didn't just give you a dollar
I just made an entry on a spreadsheet I
didn't actually physically give you a
dollar
maybe I promised to give you a dollar
maybe somebody else promised to take a
dollar out of my account and put it in
your account all sorts of things might
be true but the one thing that's not
true is that I just sent you a dollar ok
so this would not be a complete
description of any system what could be
a complete description of a system well
if I instead of saying I'm going to send
you a dollar that's just a message that
I would have to honor instead I could
actually send something like an IOU so
if I if there's a dollar on the
spreadsheet that belongs to me of course
it's not really a dollar on the
spreadsheets I can't pinpoint dollars to
a virtual spreadsheet but I could have
an IOU say an IOU from Bank of America
so for that it's useful to sort of think
about what happens when you have a Bank
of America account you log into your
online account you look at the website
and you actually see it tells you you
have money now where is that money not
actually on your computer it's not even
at Bank of America because they've lent
out you know ninety five percent of it
to someone else but so what is it that
you're seeing when you see that you have
a hundred dollars in Bank of America
you're actually seeing just a promise
Bank of America promises to give you a
hundred dollars if you ask for it that's
your relationship with Bank of America
and so Bank of America could in
principle agree that it's going to let
you keep some of those dollars like you
might have two or three different
checking and savings accounts you could
have another account which is exposed to
a some sort of virtual currency system
and when a message is sent on that
ledger that can Bank of America promise
to honor a contract to send that money
to someone else okay
so if I wanted to send money to someone
in Chase I could make an entry on the
spreadsheet using my password and if
Bank of America and Chase had already
agreed to plug into the system they
could then respond to that by actually
sending the money okay now this actually
is very close to a system that we have
today called Swift so if you want to
send money say to Europe then you're
going to send a message through
something called Swift and that message
is going to say that I'm sending someone
else money and whose account it's
supposed to go to but on the backend
that's not at all what happens on the
backend say Bank of America goes to a
correspondent bank that correspondent
Bank goes to another correspondent bank
in Europe that correspondent bank got
might go to another correspondent bank
in another country and then eventually
it's going to show up at the destination
there's a whole sort of back-end
system behind that and everybody has
agreed though that if you send a swift
message then everybody's going to honor
that message okay so that's some that's
a way so you could think about this sort
of more advanced ledger technology as
something that could be used as a
replacement for Swift the Swift only
works in certain countries and not
everybody has agreed to follow it
however if you were sending a digital
asset like a Bitcoin you wouldn't need
the whole correspondent banking system
you could just immediately send the
money and that helps understand what the
what the kind of benefit is of having
these digital currencies rather than
physical currencies they don't they
don't the the fiat currencies from
national countries require this back end
movement of money in a way that is not
necessary if you're just moving a
digital currency so I was very excited
about this idea and then and I was going
around giving these talks with sort of
this these very slides about a year and
a half ago and then I learned that a
Stanford GSB alumni named Chris Larson
had actually co-founded a company called
ripple
that had implemented a ledger just like
this that ledger allowed you to keep not
just its own native currency which it
has called the XRP but also any other
currency you wanted on the ledger and it
allowed you to use it exactly as I've
described and so today a number of
financial institutions have done just
what I described they've plugged into
the ripple ledger and they've allowed
people to put US dollar bank balances
onto the ripple ledger and then you can
use them to send money to anybody else
in the world in any other currency and
so then I joined the as an advisor for
ripple labs and now I'm on the board of
directors so it's a it's a technology
that I'm really quite excited about as
an economist the reason this was
appealing to me is that the you know I
don't want to have a bunch of consumers
and a whole bunch of of stable
developing countries holding something
other than their local currency I would
like them to think about the financial
technology innovation here is one of
being able to move money quickly but not
of one where you're just holding some
other currency on the other hand if
you're sitting in Argentina or Venezuela
or one of these very high inflation
countries it's a completely different
kettle of fish if you're a consumer in
one of those countries you have very
limited ability to save how do you save
if you're a poor consumer in a
developing country with high inflation
um you could buy a gold necklace that's
a popular way guys go to Miami and get a
suitcase full of hundred dollar bills
and come around and sell them to people
and you buy them and stuff them under
your mattress that presents some
security risks for you and your family
um if you're wealthy enough maybe you
buy a physical asset like a car or
tractor or a horse but if you don't have
enough money to do that then any cash
you have just gets inflated away very
quickly you have very little incentive
to save and very little ability to get
out of poverty a technology innovation
like this can allow people all over the
world even who don't have bank accounts
immediate access to international
financial markets because all they need
is sort of a mobile phone and instead of
someone walking around with a suitcase
full of hundred-dollar bills they can
walk around with a with a with a phone
and a little bit of cash and exchange
the cash
- for this digital asset which could
then be converted into dollars or Euros
or whatever else rather than stuffing
hundred-dollar bills under your mattress
and so this is one of the areas that's
actually happening now and that's
becoming very popular in these countries
where the existing financial systems are
quite poor this type of technology
enables a connectivity of international
financial markets in a way that's just
really never been possible it's also
going to make it very difficult for
those countries to maintain capital
controls so right now of course
recognising this they don't let people
leave that's why you have to smuggle the
suitcase full $100 bills and pay a bribe
at the airport so this is going to
really change the economics the macro
economies of those types of countries as
it becomes impossible to really enforce
capital controls in the area of digital
assets that can be moved without needing
to access the banking system so let me
give an example of this type of
international movement of money and how
it would work today and I'll give it
from the perspective of a US consumer
even though in some sense we have less
need for it than many other countries in
the world so suppose I want to spit to
send some money to Japan um if it's a
small dollar amount I could actually be
pretty much priced out of that
transaction you know Western Union or
something like that is going to charge
me 20 to 30 bucks if I do a bank to bank
account transfer that's going to cost me
you know fifty to a hundred bucks and
take a couple of days so there aren't
actually great options for making small
person-to-person international payments
and this is one use case that people
have started doing so if I wanted to
send money to Japan what I could do is
initiate a dollar transfer through a
linked account to a Bitcoin service
provider so in the u.s. the two of the
very consumer friendly ones are circling
coin base and so it's safe for example
if you want to establish an account in
Queen base I would link up my bank
account so I've done this myself with my
Bank of America account with coin base
and I they send me you know 73 cents in
in an ACH transaction and I confirm the
dollar amount so we know that we're
linked up our ACH is working and I send
them my passport and they check out Who
I am and I give them my credit card
number if I want them to actually
make funds available immediately so if I
want to have a immediate need I've got
to get some money to Japan what I can do
is I can just log on to that quickly get
on my account and say a point base you
know I want a certain sum of money so I
want you know 100 bucks give it to me
and because they've already verified me
they'll immediately make that available
on my little online web account then I
could then I can look for a quote for
what is the exchange price between
dollars and bitcoins right now so
there's a few exchanges there's a
watching a large number of exchanges but
there's a few very big ones one of them
is called bitstamp and that in on say
the bitstamp exchange you can look out
and see the order book some people want
to buy bitcoins other people want to
sell bitcoins and so you can see you
know how much how many bitcoins would i
get for my dollar and i can place an
order and then within a few minutes i
can exchange my dollars too for bitcoins
and in the case of coinbase they'll help
me do that transaction so a few minutes
later then the bitcoins show up in my in
my coin base account now all I need is
my the Bitcoin address of my friend in
Japan I tell coinbase
send my bitcoins there um and boom those
bitcoins are gone my friend in Japan has
the thing of value at that point we can
walk away we're done you know they have
the thing of value now my friend in
Japan if they want to get out of Bitcoin
quickly could then immediately take
those bitcoins on to an exchange that
operates in the Bitcoin to yen a
currency pair on that exchange that
would make another currency exchange and
get their yen out and go home okay so in
the in a very short period of time we
would have moved the thing of value
there could be delays getting in and
getting out like if I didn't have my
coin base account set up or if there
wasn't something like that in Japan they
might have to wait a little bit to turn
the Bitcoin to dollars but the point is
very very quickly they have an asset
there's a few things you have to worry
about along the way like you don't want
the exchange to go bust while you're in
the middle of a transaction that would
be bad you would lose your money but
you're not going to be on that exchange
very long at least unless you you want
to be so you really have to trust these
exchanges for a relatively short period
of time you might also worried about
fluctuations and the currency people say
well Bitcoin used to be
thousand dollars a Bitcoin and now it's
three hundred dollars of Bitcoin doesn't
that make it really bad for sending
money to Japan I can say well no
actually because it really doesn't
change very much
in the course of ten minutes and that's
really all we needed to know we needed
to know you know is it going to be
stable while we process this transaction
while we get in and out of Bitcoin and
so this is my you know from an economics
perspective I think of this is a payment
rail this is a movement a way to move
money and I got it from from here to
Japan instantly and that was very
powerful okay and but I didn't have to
hold it it's not something that I need
to hold or or use as money in my daily
life for it to be useful it can be used
for that too but it doesn't have to be
okay so this is one really crucial use
case another use case is of course just
that you know you and I could use it
with each other to split a check split a
taxi on to move money between each other
if now that all of us are starting to
ditch our wallets and only carry our
phones that would be very convenient
there in the u.s. there are some other
options like vinne mou allows you to do
that in Australia and then in Europe
actually just bank to bank transfers are
instant and free why don't we have that
good question that's a that's a question
about competition and market power but
we'll we'll get back to that so in
principle you have other ways to do that
but it's one nice way to do it
so I'll mention right now I'm in the
process of running an experiment with
MIT undergraduates where we've given
$100 worth of bitcoins to a majority of
MIT undergraduates and so we're going to
watch over time and see if when all of
their friends have them if they find
this a very useful thing to do but it
turns out that a lot of them a majority
of them were already using venmo which
is this peer-to-peer cash app and so
they already had some pretty good
cashless ways to split checks as well so
it'll be interesting to see whether you
know Bitcoin they find superior or
inferior to the mechanisms that they
already had so let me say a few more
words about use cases of this so as I
mentioned you know this international
transaction is a really big use case so
this table just so sort of the the bank
fees there's outgoing and
incoming wire transfer fees if you want
to move many money internationally so
it's not just you know the unbanked that
have to pay Western Union a lot of money
in fact Western Union is cheaper than
what your bank will offer you
remittances of course is a huge market
so the the formal remittance market is
roughly six or seven hundred billion
dollars the informal remittance market
is you know north of a trillion and
again the fees are being paid by some of
the world's most vulnerable people
people who are going off to work 70 or
80 hours a week and remit money home
they might have emergencies maybe the
folks on both ends are not that
organized with budgeting and they may
have unforeseen needs where they don't
have any kind of buffer so there's it's
fairly frequent that people are having
to send these remittances and pay fees
maybe more often than you would like and
and they become a relatively onerous
burden why are they expensive
well they on the back end on it actually
does take a fair bit of time to move
money from one country to another so
Western Union and other types of
remittance companies will generally make
the money available to the consumer on
the other end but it actually takes them
a couple of days to get their money that
means they have to hold capital and they
have to hedge their exchange rate risk
during that time period which adds to
the cost of the transaction if you were
able to eliminate those time delays you
would reduce the cost of operating these
businesses so you know some of the the
businesses that are being proposed and
built right now are cryptocurrency based
solutions where you might build a
network of on-ramps that change local
currency to Bitcoin move move it
internationally during using Bitcoin and
then cash out again so you can imagine a
set of say new stands and in one country
and a set of florists in another country
they Bo they say hey you know let's
start a remittance network you know
maybe my brother moved to a some other
country and he's got the florist and
I've got the newsstands and so you know
we're going to get together and we're
going to send the money we don't have
any capital though we just you know
we're just kind of scraping by in our
little businesses but we do have a lot
of retail outlets so without any capital
I can actually operate a remittance
business because I can move the money in
and I don't bear any risk from doing
that and so I don't have to actually
have a lot of capital nor do I have to
have my agents hold a lot of capital and
so we are seeing this kind of like
informal entrepreneurial activity
happening which can make a lot of
countries better connected than they are
today
people are also using ripple for this
and so there's a couple of remittance
companies now that are that are looking
into and improve Oh typing using ripple
as a back-end
where they are able to they don't even
have to actually touch any virtual
currency but they can just use ripple as
a payment Network to move money
instantly overseas so how does this
affect society well there's lots of
applications so we've talked about back
in money movements like remittances also
multinational firms so even very large
firms end up paying tens or even
hundreds of millions of dollars in fees
as they move money back and forth around
the world every time they move a little
money they have to pay a fee if you're
if you've got you know trillion dollars
of transactions moving back and forth
across your balance sheet over the year
even a small percentage of that adds up
to a lot and so corporate treasurers of
major companies are very unhappy with
the fees that they have to pay expecting
what service are you providing me
anyways like you're just moving my money
from me to me but why am I getting taxed
these large sums of money for this very
minimal service and so you can they also
use these very complex IT systems to
keep track of their money internally
recently Citibank lost 300 million
dollars in Mexico you know you you you
lose things um with these complex IT
systems and if everything was on sort of
a ledger say an internal ledger for the
company that was public within the
company and everybody could see where
the assets we're moving you wouldn't
lose the money and you also wouldn't
have to pay the fees or pay the IT
support costs so you know there's lots
of ideas being explored in this
direction from keeping track of
development funds and government funds
to to you know collections of firms that
are all trying to to keep their books
and in a novel way finally there's this
idea of sort of programmable money so so
getting back to the very beginning of
the
we said what was really novel and
different about Bitcoin or any other
kind of digital ledger based purely
digital asset that was kept on a ledger
and there are there many besides Bitcoin
and ripples currency XRP what was
special about those things is that you
can actually operate them on on them as
an individual
without middlemen now you might think
well I don't mind the middleman you know
I kind of trust my banks like I'm not
that worried about it but actually the
middlemen slow things down as well and
it's it's impossible to like write a
computer program that's going to execute
a complicated financial transaction
between lots of different financial
institutions they each have their own
systems and their own delays but once
the money is all digital you can
actually write computer programs on top
of it to automatically execute
transactions and that's going to allow
very new things to happen just a very
simple example is multi-sig so I want
two people to sign a cheque so I can
write a computer program that says that
you know here's this money in this
Bitcoin account but only it can only be
moved out if two people both put in
their passwords so that could help
protect you from being mugged or
anything else for your digital assets
because somebody else would have to put
in their password to in order to get the
money out
it could also protect firms um one of
the things that's getting built right
now are actual platforms for
programmable money so ripple labs has a
platform called koteas there's another
one called aetherium out there and both
of them are trying to help people write
what they call smart contracts or
computer programs that distribute money
so like the koteas platform would allow
you to write a program and it'll make it
easy for people to verify the program
works that would say if these five
things happen then this person gets paid
if these other three things happen this
other person gets paid so we could just
for example you know you could think
about some sort of complex financial
derivative we could take and is an input
the Bloomberg feed of stock prices and
we could make very complex bets about
well if this stock goes up in the stock
goes down and this other thing happens
and the National Weather Service says
it's sunny today then this person gets
paid and if these other things happen
someone else gets paid so that's going
to really reduce
the barriers to entry for creating
financial derivative products and it's
going to allow more people to hedge more
complicated situations where there's not
enough people right now to make the
market worthwhile to create the asset
and have it verified there there are
lots of other applications right now
there's many startups of some of the
smartest people in the world trying to
figure out clever things to do once
money becomes programmable and that's
really where we all have to use our
imaginations for you know what could I
do if hundreds of people who didn't know
each other all over the world could
participate in a state contingent
financial transaction that paid
different people in different
circumstances just wasn't possible
before so we're really not sure what
people are going to do with it
so what is that going to do well we're
going to see various types of changes in
industry we might see D vertical ization
of international transfers so again you
know the flower stand and the newsstand
can get together we don't need to have
big financial institutions do this banks
also may lose some of their business
because we can use you know we can hold
money in Bitcoin and we don't need to
hold in our checking account and if we
don't need to if we trust the computer
algorithms and we don't need to trust an
institution then I may be willing to
hold my money lots of other places
besides the zero interest checking
account that I have at my bank and as
banks start their services start to get
unbundled that's been a frequent
phenomenon with the internet is
something that used to all go together
now gets broken apart their business
models may change and finally we're
going to see just lots of new services
so you know things like public recording
of messages I can make an entry on the
blockchain that verifies some fact or
some piece of information and it sits in
this secure public ledger forever for
everyone to see and we can write
contracts based on that we could provide
low-friction escrow services you know
when you buy a house there's a title
agent you pay him a bunch of money and
they hold on to your money and they only
give the money to the seller when the
title changes over to the buyer we only
do that for expensive stuff but we could
do it for much cheaper stuff so Airbnb
actually expanded partly because they
unlike previous sites that did the same
service they kept the money in escrow
and the person only get paid once you
actually had your stay in the house
escrowed the funds so you can you can
imagine lots of other transactions
smaller value transactions where you
know I'm not sure I trust you enough I'm
not going to just wire money to somebody
in China to give Mandarin lessons before
I go on my business trip because I might
wire it never see the person again but
we could put it in escrow and make that
transaction possible in a way that
wouldn't have been possible before or
would have required a platform to
mediate it and take a cut
tracking flows of funds and generally I
think the theme is that we've seen from
uber to Airbnb to TaskRabbit and all the
other great new Internet platforms out
there information and contract ability
making things easier and more
frictionless and allowing people to
transact with each other without such a
level of trust has enabled huge markets
to grow where no market existed before
and digital money is going to allow that
to happen in new services and
applications as well as making existing
ones more efficient so this is basically
why I'm so excited about this technology
not because I think you should speculate
in Bitcoin and buy it at 300 and hope it
goes to a thousand but because it
fundamentally it's like the internet a
new technology that allows things to
happen that couldn't happen before and
we have a whole range of some of the
world's brightest entrepreneurs trying
to figure out what to build on it the
first wave of the may go bust but
eventually I have a lot of faith that
the way that we move money is going to
catch up with the way that we move
information today thanks very much